there's something seriously more
dangerous about the kovat virus than was
previously thought and it's only just
becoming apparent Italian doctors and
researchers are increasingly concerned
that there's been a huge underestimation
of the sheer severity of Kovac 19 these
are not coronavirus patients but in this
region there is a spike in psychosis
kidney disease spinal infections strokes
chronic tiredness and mobility issues
the virus inflames all the organs in the
body putting everyone at risk
still dr. Roberto Cosentino oversaw the
emergency response in Bergamo one of the
worst affected towns in the north of the
country he's concerned there will be
another kovat surge here on top of the
ongoing damage to survivors subsequently
we discover that it is a systemic
illness with vessel damage you know the
whole body with renal involvement a
cerebral involvement and so within other
acute and equipment physicians acute
renal failure that requested dialysis or
a stroke and then acute myocardial
infarction so we saw a lot of
complications of are manifestations of
the virus and also now we see a
significant proportion of population
with chronic damage from for the virus
the pandemic that swept through these
hospitals created an almost unique
environment where doctors and experts in
different fields found themselves
working together for months effectively
learning new skills doctor Emanuela
catenaccio is a neurologist who was
co-opted to work on the intensive care
ward she's now back on neurology
crucially whereas in the past she would
have treated her patients completely
independent of
departments now she can see the link and
that link is Kovac
it's a multi-organ killer systemic
infection some our paratus organs at the
biggest manifestation such lungs no but
also brain skins skin and sometimes we
have vasculitis not it's not so high
respiratory or lower spirit or
infectious is not finished vet here all
Kovac victims are being constantly
monitored and tested they're trying to
gauge the long-term effects of the
disease they're beginning to fear that
some may never recover Filippo Alki any
has been covered fully for four months
but he still struggles to breathe or
live a normal life Eve awkwardly
conventional hospital money on tell Leah
or una cita Monaco profit oh you know
velocity mana di star malakoma sono
stato Molly okay for checkup it cannot
be known so too volatile atonte don t as
practicable mo can fall so dearest Aria
I repaired it seems that the corona
virus may appear to calm down or at
least continuing waves but it is ongoing
it's a worldwide disaster still but the
doctors here are saying is that people
must listen they are seeing people who
had mild kovat symptoms coming into
hospital with serious illnesses
illnesses that might stay with them for
the rest of their lives and once again
they're emphasizing you must wash your
hands you must keep up social distancing
and you must wear a mask the hospital
wards had Lombardi the worst-hit area in
Italy a quiet now but the long-term
effects of the virus on society is
ongoing a second wave remains a
possibility but the effects of the first
wave go on
Steele Ramsey skynews Lombardi